so i hate to have to break it to you
today and to start the show on such a
negative note uh especially to
my progressive audience members but
unless something changes
with a high likelihood donald trump is
very rapidly barreling towards
re-election in 2020
and this is why i've been very careful
not to make any statements when i report
about
oh you know georgia could conceivably be
in play texas could conceivably be in
play
uh there are a lot of uh ifs ands and
buts attached to that and before we get
into the issues based components of my
commentary today
let's just deal with the math quickly
because there are people who are just
putting way too much confidence
in the polling data that shows trump not
doing well in north carolina and georgia
and texas and trump's approval rating is
tanking
and then there are also people who just
don't believe me when i say that donald
trump
can get re-elected even despite a very
low
approval rating the reality is that what
we saw in 2004
is the case anytime you're trying to
unseat an incumbent president which is
it's really difficult donald uh trump uh
certainly very different than george w
bush in many ways but as difficult as it
was to remove bush in 2004
ultimately not being removed of course
even someone as
malignantly ignorant and acutely
narcissistic as donald trump will be
difficult
to remove now from a mathematical
perspective when half the country
doesn't vote
and you have an electoral college system
that systemically
favors republicans in all of the ways
that we've talked about before
donald trump's 36 or 38 or 40 percent
approval rating
can easily get him reelected now i've
said before
you can construct the math such that
it's possible to get reelected even with
27 approval
and it's true but if you disagree with
me about that or you think it's an
exaggeration
it's not even worth arguing about
because trump's approval rating isn't
that low and there's no indication it's
going to go
that low so with the math piece out of
the way
let's look at what democrats are doing
so far bearing in mind that we're still
in the pre-primary phase democrats need
to run good campaigns
with progressive ideas that are popular
of course
but democrats also need to at least
somewhat appeal
to red state voters and moderates in
purple states on the issues that clearly
matter right now as i've said before
as a strategy get out the vote is much
more powerful
than arguing with trumpists but
it still makes sense to at least stake
out
positions generally speaking that will
be
reasonable to some fraction of those
moderate republican voters now there's a
necessary disclaimer here
i'm being strategic here i'm not talking
about what i like
and what my politics are i'm talking
about winning 2020.
think about immigration first it's
disgusting
what's happening at the border it's a
real humanitarian crisis
but most of the conversations that
democratic candidates are having
are ridiculous and debate moderators are
hugely to blame for this as i've talked
about before
what's happening with the discussion
around deportations
on the right is an absolute fantasy
right i mean
we're not going to deport 12 million
people who are in the united states
illegally
nor would we want to deport the 12
million people
that are in the united states illegally
if people are committing violent crimes
and they're here illegally okay they're
now you're talking about people that it
makes sense to deport
but the reality is that there are
multiple industries that depend on these
undocumented immigrants including
agriculture
including the restaurant industry and
they're a hugely positive influence on
our society both economically and
culturally
from any number of standpoints
from an american dream standpoint from a
work ethic standpoint in basically every
way that we can imagine
almost all of these undocumented
immigrants are actually a positive force
here in the united states at the same
time
democrats need to throw a bone to
centrist and republican voters
around the need to have a defensible
border a defended
border i've already debunked the idea of
the wall endless times and democrats
don't need to
you know pretend to be aggressive
neocons on the wall or
even dabble with the xenophobic or
racist stuff but
something needs to be done to just
merely get on the record to republican
voters that democratic candidates
understand the concerns
there will be a defensible border and no
one is advocating for open borders
because they're going to try to smear
all the democratic candidates
as being in favor of open borders when
of course that's not the case
it should just be made clear that no one
is advocating for open borders
because that's the truth but a little
more is going to need to be done and
said if we don't want to have the exact
repetition of the 2016 election this
isn't controversial right every country
in the world
that is an interesting and appealing
place for people to come to from other
countries
is going to have a defended border this
wouldn't change under a democratic
president
let's just like go five percent further
in making that clear but like i've said
before
we end up with all of this you know
raise your hands if you'd give
undocumented
immigrants health care even if that's a
morally correct position
to take uh it's a losing position if
that becomes the focus in the national
election and democrats need to make damn
sure
that that doesn't actually become the
focus no matter what
debate moderators are going to try to do
okay let's talk about farmers
and the midwest which we've been talking
about for months at this point in time
you have farmers in the midwest who are
aware that it's donald trump's tariffs
that have been a disaster for them
but merely saying i will reverse the
tariffs as many democratic candidates
have been saying
is not going to convince a lifelong
midwestern republican
to vote for a democrat and i've said
this before
when we hear about all of these trump
voters in the midwest who are
angry with trump or disapprove of trump
or our farmers and recognize that trump
is ruining their businesses
that doesn't mean that you're going to
go out and vote for a democrat in
november of 2020. lifelong republicans
who don't approve of trump aren't
necessarily voting
for joe biden or bernie sanders or
elizabeth warren
so something more needs to be done there
and it generally relates to the economic
anxieties of middle america
that hillary clinton didn't do a good
job of addressing in an appropriate
enough way
this is just the reality i'm not saying
the narrative about disadvantaged white
people
is based in any reality it's ridiculous
what i am
saying is that without addressing some
of these issues in a smart
way trump gets reelected period
this gets me to the distraction attempts
that have been very successful by the
right
when donald trump generates a firestorm
around whether this or that person is
racist
or whether a comment was racist or
whatever
these are important issues but they are
not
issues that are going to get swing state
voters
to abandon donald trump or motivate
anyone to get out and vote
if they see an endless focus and debate
over
whether this or that comment was racist
as an example
now i know that there are people on the
left who won't like this but
it's just the reality and then
unfortunately i spoke a year ago about
my desire for this not to happen
democrats and their supporters are
starting to slam each other
in a way that could be self-destructive
and just help donald trump
we are seeing i'm going in no particular
order here
we're seeing a rise of a no biden no way
contingent
and i agree that joe biden is not a
progressive but i also remember
all those people who said in 2016 who
cares hillary would be the same as trump
and of course they couldn't have been
more wrong look at the supreme court
look at the 25 percent of judges that
donald trump
has appointed and we're reminded every
day
that and the geopolitical belligerence
and now
trying to collude with enforcing
collusion with another country ukraine
we'll talk about that later
could not have been more different from
hillary clinton so that's a concern
then we have the growing group of bernie
supporters
focusing their ire on elizabeth warren
even mass unsubscribing from my youtube
channel last week when i pointed out hey
in 60 of recent polls warren has
surpassed bernie into second place
this group claiming warren is a tool of
the establishment disguised to appear
progressive and i'm
a shill merely for mentioning poll
results bernie and warren are not the
same
that's clear but that is another
contingent
that is potentially self-destructive and
it's getting to the point where it could
be damaging in the general election
the tulsi people i've already talked
about andrew yang's followers who
although relatively small mathematically
are getting extremely angry with just
like everything every anything that
happens they're absolutely furious about
then you've got biden supporters who are
falling
for the often repeated right-wing
talking points about
bernie and warren are extreme
they are radical they're too far left
they're even talking about the term
socialism that's the
contingent of biden supporters that's
terrible
this is the type of stuff that will
propel donald trump to reelection
because it feeds narratives that are not
useful to the left so i'm not saying
this because i'm looking to attack
a particular candidate or the supporters
of a particular candidate this isn't
even about
particular candidates this is merely
pragmatism we saw what happened in 2016
and unless we prevent these things i'm
mentioning from getting completely out
of control
it's going to happen again and we'll
have four more years of trump now there
are people in the audience
who would rather have four more years of
trump
than whoever you don't like from the
democratic primary right there are
people who would say
burn it all down let trump do whatever
he wants to do
because it's better than having whoever
it is that's running in the democratic
primary
i just disagree with that as a strategy
i think that the more we look at history
the more we realize
that what has worked historically is not
uh foregoing small changes we could
make right now with the idea of
eventually burning it all down and
building it back up in a perfect image
of what is perfectly aligned
with our political ideology that's not
the way it's worked
in the last however many however however
many years you consider to be modern
politics
that's simply not a strategy that's
worked so i'm open to having my mind
changed if you think you can convince me
that the let trump have another four
years burn it all down and then we'll be
in a much better position for 2024
mentality if you want to try to convince
me of that
i'm more than open to hearing from you
but it's not something that i see backed
by history
it's not something i see backed by logic
and it's not something that seems like
the right approach
let me know what you think i'm open to
having my mind changed about
all of this but i am increasingly
concerned because i don't want to see
another four years of donald trump yeah
i know it'd be great for the show
but i care about the country even more
than that uh
and i want to hear from you if you
disagree with me i'm on twitter
deepakman
the show is on twitter at
davidpakmanshow